foreign
[Music]
Jolie spotted hanging out with normal
people star Paul meskel here's what we
know the actress had a girls night out
with her 16 year old daughter Shiloh
when your children are your best friends
it's kind of a it's a nice life the two
went to see A Streetcar Named Desire in
London which Paul is currently starring
in and after the night's performance
Paul hit up a cafe with the
mother-daughter Duo check them out
seated at a table inside the cafe and
onlooker tells E.T they chatted for at
least 20 minutes and seemingly had the
place to themselves the eyewitness
described quote it looked like Angelina
was complimenting Paul and his
performance he seemed a bit nervous and
was touching his arm a lot now as far as
we know this was just a friendly ketchup
but the sighting does come as
speculation swirls that Paul's newly
single having reportedly split from his
supposed fiancee Phoebe Bridgers who
knows who knows romance rumors between
Paul and Phoebe first surfaced in 2020
when the singer called him the cute boy
in an interview quote I got a little
pitter patter in my heart when I saw he
followed my Instagram
Paul ended up starring in her savior
complex music video that same year
[Music]
the two then made the romance red carpet
official in 2021 at the LACMA art and
film Gala
fast forward to November 2022 the pair
was said to be engaged though they never
confirmed that and in weeks following
Phoebe was actually spotted out a few
times with someone else comedian Bo
Burnham people who resonate with me will
find me both Phoebe and Paul have yet to
comment on their current relationship
status so until then paulus hang with
Angelina will just fuel more
conversation
[Music]
foreign